There are so many people that are better cooks than I am.
I think my strength is being able to be personable with people and like make
sure that they like feel really nourished and happy.
Big Old,
beautiful trees that were here before me.
There'll be who after me.
The farm always keeps me humble.
These are stamen winds up apple trees.
I've got about 70 trees here.
I do the pruning by myself.
It takes me about five to eight hours per tree.
On an average day.
When I'm cooking for a client,
I'll usually start at the farmer's market.
I try to find the most unusual produce and I make something I've never made
before with it.
So that's also on the list for today.
This is where everybody is funnels through here.
When they're done with her,
you pick with my meatballs,
whatever sauce I put on,
I also sell about sauce.
Okay.
Hi,
what is this?
This is the old boy.
Tiny squat.
Oh,
okay.
Thank you.
Oh,
interesting.
It is Tempura and sometimes I don't necessarily have all those ingredients at
home,
but we could get them.
I did some searching online for some recipes that looked legit.
So we're just going to grab a few items.
Oh yeah.
There's already a line out there.
As soon as we open up the gate,
um,
if you guys can help me get the signs out there.
It feels so weirdly prepared.
Good morning everybody.
How are we ready to pick some apples today?
Okay.
If you're wanting to pick apples,
we're harvesting our stamen wine PSAP apples today.
Woo.
It is hot.
Where are you visiting from?
Downy.
Okay.
Not too far.
Damn.
This mint smells so good.
This is a combination of ingredients for salads,
for a client,
lunches to take to work and then also ingredients for my nausea.
With Tosh Instagram,
I actually started cooking pretty late in life.
I want it to be an actor like everybody else in their mother.
I didn't like the food at school.
I was like,
I kind of want to find a way to merge performing and food.
Dude,
I'm 58 I was in my early thirties we were just driving by and I just fell in
love with the land itself.
We moved here and then um,
you know,
I'm making $3,000 for a whole year's labor.
So that's when we decided,
well,
we were going to try and do you pick on farm?
I got a job at assisting teaching cooking classes and then it just sort of like
snowballing private chef work and doing notch Latasha.
And for the most part I've been really lucky.
I'm obsessed with the salad spinner in the video that I just put out where I
made a Frittata,
it was a video sponsored by Oxo.
Um,
I'm wearing a suit and a shirt,
a lost of the meatballs.
Today we're going to cook 40 pounds of meat balls.
I started out just going to trader Joe's,
getting the little meatballs there,
and then it got to where I would come in and wipe out the whole refrigerator
supply area.
And Vince,
when I realized like I've grown past the trader Joe's thing,
these are frozen solid.
There are definitely certain laws about the amount that you can cook at home for
Heb legal.
Until recently it was like $60,000.
If I had all the money in the world.
This is where I live.
I love this like Cradley area between the Palisades in Santa Monica.
Okay,
so fine.
45 which totals gonna be 1130 please.
How the 20 I get you a little bag there for your goodies.
Thank you very much.
You guys have a great day for little tiny farms like me.
You have to diversify because I can work my best and a hail storm can come and
wipe out my crop in one day.
We've shot movies here.
We've had print ads.
I'd done some weddings,
so took some heat for that,
so I stopped doing that.
Right?
My neighbor complained and that's how the first,
you know,
county permitting issues came about when code enforcement came out.
They're like,
I can't believe somebody complaining about this.
Beautiful Barb.
But if you're a powerful person up here,
what you complain about will be taken care of.
Sure.
When do you need it?
When I do recipe testing for branded content,
it's a little bit like ghost writing,
if you will.
What I'm working on right now is a spicy fried chicken that you can tuck inside
of a bubble waffle.
The first thing I do is make them a bunch of times and then I'll just send them
guideline photos,
so this will take me about three hours and I bill for this type of work at $100
an hour.
Yesterday we grossed about 3,800 when we're busy,
they're more like $8,000 days.
You might think that $8,000 sounds like a lot for a day,
but there's going to be months when there's no income,
but the work still continues here.
The next notch photosh episode that I have coming out is Thai pumpkin soup.
So this already,
this first piece has to go because it's just too long when like someone else is
paying you to do the recipe,
you have to follow very specific guidelines and it has to be like really
professional.
Yeah,
and this just feels so like this is just me hanging out
who's ready to pick some apples.
Anyway,
before I send you on your way,
I'm going to give you a couple of tips.
When you're picking one apple,
you might have a few more come down.
Okay.
I've never been motivated by money,
which makes me a terrible business woman.
When I do preschool tourism,
I top out at 48 kids.
My neighbors might bring in six different schools at one time.
When buses there,
there's one predominant family and they have almost a total monopoly.
They probably make more money than me.
I would imagine that they're not picking up apples every morning like I am.
Yes.
Could I make a lot of money really fast?
I think that's what some of my competition does and I've just always take him to
the exact opposite approach.
Looking pretty good on that tractor.
Alright.
Hey,
don't know how to know how old and Opo is.
Oh,
cool.
Wow.
It really does look like a cross between a squash and a cucumber with the seeds
in the center,
it has a little bit of a like a Slimy Mountain Yam texture.
My favorite thing.
Now we're at a perfect deep fry.
These look like a stupid American native more or
Oh Whoa,
we sold a lot of the other one.
Yeah,
pretty much every day I'm open.
I have people come in kind of stricken.
You know why Sarah for sale side?
I had intended to do it longer,
but I'm also one that believes that you got to listen to what the universe is
telling you.
I wonder if I'll ever feel comfortable with where I'm at.
I hear like that sort of like,
I know a lot of people who are way,
way,
way more successful than me that I think also have this same like internal
desire to continue like growing and doing better.
I can comfortably afford my life and do it in a flexible way,
but do I feel like I'm where I want to be?
No.
When my neighbors are complaining to the county,
when the county is giving me cease and desist orders,
it takes the joy away.
The problem with doing what you love,
she puts her heart and soul into it,
you know?
So,
which is what people love about it.
But you know,
it makes it hard when you,
what do you might need to leave?
My kids are like,
mom worked so hard.
Get out and go do something else.
Maybe it's just time.
I tried to make a lot of time for friends and to like be a good neighbor and
like brighten people's days in small ways.
I Dunno.
I Dunno how much your happiness should be connected to your success.
I give,
that's just an unwinnable I trick.
I don't know.
But
if that was all that I connected my happiness to like,
then I wouldn't be happening.
Mother Nature is pretty amazing.
You know,
when you stand next to a tree like this,
I'm going to imagine all the history that's occurred in a hundred years that's
still here and it's still standing and it's still producing beautiful apples.